what a dynamite season in all pro season
uh from the buffalo bills stefan diggs
how have you been stefan
my god how you doing thanks for having
me always nice talking to you how are
things
i am doing fine i am better for talking
to you dream season right is this what
you dreamt of
is this what you thought of when you uh
when you were acquired by buffalo
i wouldn't say i got that far at it in
the beginning of it
i was just excited to be where i was i
was excited to be around it guys where i
was like getting to know josh
uh 17 is a hell of a god that's that
that coaching staff and the player that
they have are truly special
so i was really just focusing on that
and that new family and that new you
know that new environment earning my
keep earning my stripes earning my
respect to my teammates
and then things kind of just fell out in
front of me things kind of just
the ball just got to rolling and it got
bigger and bigger and snowball effect
and good things happen
so uh josh told me when i uh interviewed
him for
uh the pregame show prior to the fc
championship game that you and he
are brothers but very competitive like
that you
actually compete walking down the
hallway to see you can walk the fastest
is that true is that really a true story
that story is true actually he caught me
one time walking uh from the weight room
and i was like this like why is he
walking so fast so i sped up a little
bit
and then he continued to speed him and
then he just took off so i was like
obviously there's a competition between
quarterback and receiver and it'll never
stop so
really yes this is something i'm never
gonna never gonna give up uh we compete
on video games who has the most kills
and
who carries who it's just i think it
makes for a great relationship though
no i i hear you and i i asked this
question with the utmost of respect
stefan so please understand that
uh talking about walking down the
hallway fastest and playing video games
what are you guys five
are you guys five years old gotta be
five years older we're writing on the
walls we're getting in trouble by
we'll we'll be joking around in the
walk-through and you'll have coach dave
all come in and
he's he's super serious but at the same
time he jokes sometimes and he'll crack
a joke he's like all right all right
uncle here get your butts back to work
and it's it makes for a great
environment great working round well we
saw that can't touch this
uh dance-a-thon that broke out before
your first playoff game we saw that
was that your doing your influence at
all or steve
it's the team big guy like everybody's
we're not super uptight we're about our
work we we get in we get into practice
and we work extremely hard
but while we do it we like to have a
little bit of enthusiasm a little bit of
good energy i tell coach mcdermott all
the time give me some of that good
positive energy i need something
he always got it so uh it's definitely
just a team that's made up
made up of the right stuff stefan diggs
here uh on the rich eisen show
so let me just um now go to the way the
season ended here
the photograph of you staring at the
chief's celebration
accepting the uh lamar hunt trophy yeah
to win the afc
why did you do this why did you go out
and do this look at it
from from the most you know open place i
i'll tell you rich i was hurt uh rich
i'm a champion i look at myself as a
champion i look at myself as a winner
and part of me felt like i let my team
down i didn't do enough obviously i
didn't do enough
the better team won that day and i
wanted to you know not only just pay my
respect
in a way but be a part of just you know
the better team one give them their give
them that credit they're a good ass
football team they're a team that went
out there
and did everything they can they could
to win that game so it hurt me to watch
it and i felt like i needed to watch it
to further you know more motivation more
you know feel to the fire that
when you get back there you want a
different result but remember this
feeling and i needed to
i needed to go through it sometimes you
need to go through it get through it to
go through it whatever holiday saying
goes
right but why need i mean why why you
know i i
i've been a god that's built on has been
built off of adversity
my whole life i've been to i went to
maryland university of maryland i stayed
home i didn't get drafted early
all the reasons i had chips on your
shoulder i got them and you know i had
my slices of humble pie
from god as many times as i could here's
here goes another one
you know it's a moment where the season
went so well so many things fairy tale
story
but i didn't get all the way there you
know so it's something for me to look
back on and be like this
why didn't you get all the way there
could you have done things better and
embrace that moment so as far as i could
need i felt like
you need to go through those things like
i went through a lot of my previous
situation to get to where i am
now so this isn't nothing different i've
been through i've been through bigger so
uh just more motivation what did you go
through in your previous situation
stefan diggs come on now
i would say uh i always just say things
things weren't as peachy as they are now
were you were you playing video games
with your previous quarterback
i don't know i think that's i'm just
blaming on myself i wasn't playing
enough video games with all my guys man
one thing i can say if you're playing
video games and you're making handshakes
with your
with your guys you're on the right track
and i needed to do more of that
i learned though i learned them okay and
so yeah how are you a different guy now
through this season than you were when
you were acquired from buffalo
it's different i feel like i'm the same
guy i just feel like uh my surroundings
are a little different
you know i was dealing with a younger
quarterback you know a lot of the guys
that were pretty much are established
or were in the league for a very long
time i was dealing with a young
charismatic
uh big heart guy that want to jump over
linebackers and run people over and step
on big ones
i was dealing with a quarterback that i
that's young and i was uh i
came at a great time to grow with so
it's just you know all situations are
different but this one was one that
uh it coincided and it worked well
stefan diggs here uh
on the rich eisen show okay how do you
see super bowl 55 stefan break it down
for me oh
it's tough rich the last time they
played it was what 27 to 24.
i mean i'm anticipating uh that usual
high tempo
or high octane offense of kansas city
and then you got a a tabo's defense that
you know they played a pretty good game
the first time they played them you know
they did not play a bad game trying to
contain target kill was one thing he had
some big plays in the first half so
you eliminate those big plays you got a
different game at least and i say it's
it's hard to beat a team twice so you
can obviously know who i'm going with
my favorite player is tom so uh i'm
gonna go with tommy we can see what
father tom can do
what do you mean he's your favorite
player what do you mean by that
he exemplifies the game of football and
how you supposed to approach the game
appreciate the game
and he has a passion his passion is
never mistaken for anything other
than passion not a distraction not
anything it's coming from the
quarterback position and it trickles
down
something that you know i have a lot of
respect for and you know i respect him
as a
as a as a not even just a player you
know how he approaches life so
that's that's my favorite guy so are you
saying your passion was mistaken in
minnesota is that what you're saying i'm
just gonna hit the nail right on the
head there what do you think i'm saying
that it could have been
it definitely could have been because at
times uh it could have been a
distraction but anybody who knows me
knows i want to win
and i want to win by any means i don't
care how we got to do it and i feel like
if we're not doing the right way
uh we gotta find a way to win so it
could have been mistaken that at times a
hundred percent
but i came into this situation the same
person that i was and as i was
on the sideline i had trainers and i had
coaches telling me that
they never had that before they never
had that type of that type of energy on
this island of
me going to my alarm and not only you
know saying uh
like let's go let's get ready to go we
got to be better i demand better from
y'all we got to do better
other than that i don't just scold i
just be back there having their backs
when they have a
hell of a drive blocking or you know
against the pictures they were blocking
blocking their butts off and i was like
this that's how you guys brought you
guys did a great job and
you know just being that voice of your
team not just not just coming from a
place of just i'm a receiver i'm over
here telling llamas
thank you for blocking even if we not
throwing the ball coming from a
person of you know not only just
leadership just really
embracing the guys that you're around
and they don't they never got it
mistaken not once
so uh before i let you go then sir uh
what are you doing with the old spice
oh i'm talking a little bit about their
new dynasty old spice dynasty you know
throughout this pandemic
um some men might have been on the couch
not using as much deodorant so
it's a rich rich i'ma send you a little
package to uh okay to get acclimated
with but uh
yeah that's uh that's what i'm talking
about a little bit today it's staying
ready at all times
smelling good i'm a guy that's big on
hygiene and i like to smell good so okay
it's definitely something to look into
you can find it at your local target
well that's i think why you and i get
along so well i'm very hygienic i'm a
very high general person
but i'm also somebody that is not
ashamed to accept free stuff so
there you go okay so you understand um
that we're
we're kind of locked up like that old
spice dynasty again available at target
um and uh one of the best targets in all
of
football stefan diggs uh so super bowl
56 out here in la
um you know what what do you what do you
think do i see you up the road here
do we get to spend some time in person
you got to tell me
hopefully i don't see you i don't have
any time to have this conversation
because we're
hard working at practice no i understand
that but you'd still find time for me
though right stephanie
yeah yeah that's what friends do that's
okay that's amazing i want to make sure
about that all right
and uh you know uh interestingly enough
you know who's playing in so far this
weekend uh
is your friend steve harvey um from uh
from family feud
um yes yes dear friend different family
few i don't know if you caught that
episode i was on
oh i did stefan leave it blank leave it
blank leave it blank
catch it again for that all right oh no
it's okay
no bruce smith one upped you from the
buffalo bills on that
i got to see it oh go google bruce smith
family feud as soon as you hang up for
me and understand you are no longer
in the leader in the clubhouse as a
buffalo bill in terms of moments with
steve harvey
don't worry about it take care of
yourself stefan you'll be well
you got that stefan diggs the one and
only that's stefan diggs with an f
in case you uh don't know on twitter and
instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here